foreign
starting off this hour in Green Bay
Wisconsin hi Brittany welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi Dave thank you for having me sure
what's up
I am calling and originally inquiring
because my husband and I are about nine
hundred thousand dollars in debt we're
both 29 years old and we have a large
logging business which consumes the
majority of our debt
um we're just trying to figure out what
we can do to minimize this if not get
rid of it completely and get on track to
not continually adding debt but getting
rid of it yeah
so what is um
give me a little breakdown on this
apparently you've got a bunch of heavy
equipment in the logging world right yes
absolutely so we have two pieces of
equipment right now one is valued at
around eight hundred thousand dollars
and the other is valued around 500 000
so those two big pieces and what is what
is owed on those
so we have the smaller machine paid off
so that there's nothing on that that's
full equity and then we owe around 640
on the larger piece of equipment right
now gotcha okay and
um so that's 640 out of 900.
correct yeah and so what is the other
250.
we have
personal personal yes yes okay um that
will be changing I'm not sure yeah yeah
it's definitely going to be changing so
what what's next
um we have only well around seven
thousand dollars in credit cards right
now so
um what else then we have 90 000 in a
mortgage
um
okay so there's no other business down
no that's still you're still 200 000
short or a hundred thousand dollars
short where's the rest of it
um we got an
what a hundred thousand two hundred
thousand
two hundred thousand okay all right
what's the net profit of your logging
business in a year
taxable taxable taxable income
yep around 300. okay good news all right
okay and um
you said you're going to be doing
something to clear these vehicles which
is good because they're out of control
um
and so really you the the bulk of this
by far is one piece of equipment
correct sir yep okay so there's two two
ways to attack this number one it's a
little bit complicated but uh just
follow me through here what we teach
folks in entree leadership when they
have a business that has debt is you
need to bring home the minimum you can
operate your house with
let's just call that a hundred for
discussion purposes
okay
okay and you bring 100 home you clear
off a bunch of these vehicles you use
the hundred to get rid of the credit
card debt and the the mortgage you're
just going to pay your mortgage until we
get to baby step seven right but we're
gonna clear these vehicles by selling
them and or reducing them with your
hundred that leaves us two hundred
thousand to address 800
000 worth of debt at the business
okay
right and so if you say
I'm gonna put uh of that 200 I'm gonna
put uh one 175 towards debt every year
and 25 in retained earnings every year
I'm gonna put 25 000 in retained
earnings in it to buy new equipment and
to fix the old equipment and for
emergencies and that kind of thing and
then I'm clearing this SBA loan and I'm
clearing this piece of equipment and of
course the other thing you could
consider is that this piece of equipment
was a mistake
and it needs to be sold to pay off the
debt that was my question is it a nest a
completely necessary piece of equipment
or is it something that you can do
without
in order to maintain the business now
could we get a less expensive option
absolutely that would be you know use no
warranty all of those things on that
yeah um but it is an option to get a a
cheaper machine you want to ask yourself
here's the thing you want to look at
when you're buying things for business
anything you buy for business is an
investment
okay and Investments aren't toys
so an investment for business is what is
the minimum thing the minimum purchase
that will do the job
do the job requires that it has that it
is uh especially we're dealing with
Fleet and you're dealing with equipment
do the job means it has to start it has
to operate can't break down all the time
right so it can't be a piece of crap
that's not doing the job but the other
thing is we don't have to have the
fanciest one
with a GPS on it and the microwave oven
in the cab
yeah absolutely if you were to sell this
piece of equipment and get a used piece
what's the price difference there
I almost probably around 200 000.
to purchase a used one
oh no that would be the difference okay
so you'd buy yeah are you interested in
a four instead of 650 you'd pay for it
you'd have 450 in debt yeah yeah
absolutely yeah yeah well here's the
thing if I'm looking at this what I'm
going to do to answer your question is
we teach people take your net profit
after you've taken a living wage out and
put a percentage of all your net dollars
towards growing retained earnings and
everything else on the debt and no more
purchases with debt until we have this
debt cleared
right and then we pay cash for all
future purchases so you got to make this
piece of equipment last if you're gonna
sweat to pay it off because it's going
to take you like four years to clear
this
yes yes absolutely but it's doable I
mean it's doable that doesn't mean it
was a smart thing it doesn't mean it's
what I would do it's not I mean the way
I would go at it if you had it to do
over I would have purchased the 200 000
cheaper one
and I would have saved up and paid cash
for it because that's how I do stuff
here I mean I've got tens of millions of
dollars of hard Assets in this building
um and this one room has about five
miles of wire running through it right
where we do studio in right and so we've
got cameras sitting here that cost a
bazillion dollars we've got everything
else all this stuff we have sitting
around here but you know it's the it's
we don't buy the we buy what we call uh
MF minimal functional minimum functional
what what how can it function at a
minimum and because you know the thing
is you gotta if it's Electronics yeah
and if it for that matter if it's a
piece of equipment it's got a shelf life
before it's just not worth anything
that's right yeah you imagine if we're
still trying to operate with non-hd
cameras in this HD world yeah I'd be
that's that just tells me I'm old right
I mean I used to be on the air with
non-hd cameras you know so uh
before HD
I was on Fox Business when it was HD and
fox wasn't wow yeah when they first came
out it was uh so there's a day you know
but all of a sudden those cameras poof
instantaneously worth zero just like
that